uh this is very interesting to see
republican senator and trump brown-noser
rand paul
went on fox news this weekend and tried
to pawn off on fox news host chris
wallace this
silly notion that donald trump can't be
tried
for his impeachment after being out of
office
now remember that even though legally
trump can be impeached after leaving
office
he was impeached while in office but the
trial is happening afterwards it's
happening
now there's nothing unconstitutional
about this there's really nothing
particularly remarkable remarkable about
that but rand paul
tries that failed argument on chris
wallace
and chris wallace shuts it down and
rightly so let's look at the first clip
the other side argues that under that
standard a president could
abuse his power quit at the last minute
and could not be held accountable by the
senate for
obviously if it's if it's a legal crime
he could be but for a political crime
the senate would be unable to touch him
under your standard
i think that argument ignores the fact
that yes the president can be prosecuted
and if they think he incited a riot or
an insurrection
which is such an overstatement and such
a conclusion without any sort of
presentation of evidence all the
left-wing media just concludes it
but the thing is is yes they can take
him to court they can take him to trial
and do it
i think he has suffered under public
opinion his numbers are greatly reduced
and so i think there's all kinds of
punishment but we have to look we've had
a country for 250 years
and every other congress thought it was
unwise to keep you know
going after an ex-president so that's
actually
super slippery of rand paul rand paul
throws together a bunch of different
arguments there now they're all bad
arguments but when you put them all
together
it sounds sort of like wow that that was
a lot of arguments lots of reasons
why trump can't be tried now but don't
let him gish gallop you
let's actually think through each of the
arguments first rand paul says
if trump incited uh if trump incited an
insurrection
there can be legal repercussions trump
could be charged criminally
trump could be prosecuted criminally he
could be convicted he could be sentenced
criminal
criminally now that's first of all a red
herring because it has nothing to do
with the house and senate the house and
senate don't have that power
the house and senate don't have the
responsibility of being involved
in the criminal prosecution of a
president the house looks at actions and
asks
did it meet the threshold for an
impeachment if the answer is yes then
they impeach
and then the senate holds its trial and
evaluates the evidence
law enforcement can do whatever it wants
but it has nothing to do with the house
and senate so it's a red herring
but rand paul also wants to have it both
ways because it's been these same
republicans arguing for more than four
years
that you can't charge a president for
crimes committed while in office it's
sort of like a
if the president does it it's not a
legal defense and now rand paul wants it
both ways
then rand says trump has suffered enough
because his approval is down as he left
office
that's also a non-argument it's like
being saying listen
the crimes you committed were
embarrassing so we're not going to
prosecute you it doesn't work that way
so it's another
distraction and then rand paul says
in the past congress chose not to
impeach
former presidents but again it's
factually wrong
since trump was impeached while in
office
it's the trial that's happening now and
it doesn't matter that that's how it was
done in the past the fact that in the
past
choices were made one way doesn't mean
it's unconstitutional to do it
differently today and that was his main
thing that it's unconstitutional
so rand paul moving the goal posts the
question was about the constitutionality
and now he says well trump's already
been embarrassed
and you could charge him criminally and
in the past we didn't do it this way
none of that is about constitutionality
let's look at a little more
and here chris wallace just shuts it
down con constitutional scholars
like professional which have said that
the constitution says you impeach
and disqualify if the person isn't there
to impeach you can't do either one of
them
and so there are constitutional experts
senator paul
also before my colleague senator paul
that's not quite true if
if i may if i may in 1876
the then secretary of war william belnap
serving under ulysses s
grant was about to be impeached for
accepting bribes
he raced to the white house and resigned
but the house impeached him anyway
and the senate decided that it had the
authority to try him and it did
try him and although a majority sought
to remove him to convict him they didn't
get the two thirds but isn't that
the 1876 case of william belnap
a solid precedent no because we've never
impeached a president because we always
thought it would destroy and tear up the
country and divide us further
so that's another slippery attempt from
rand paul chris wallace says
isn't my example an example of how this
clearly
is constitutional and rand says
no because that wasn't a president and
doing it to a president would divide the
country
why are we talking about dividing the
country if the initial argument rand
paul was making was about
constitutionality it's completely
pathetic but
what is what is sad you know what i i
know i've said this before but
trump saying i'm going to run for
president wacky people
choose to run for president all the time
in many countries
that's not really the problem the
problem was
that in the republican party primary
electorate
you had so many people willing to vote
for donald trump that was really
the problem and if it weren't for the
republican electorate it wouldn't make a
difference
much the same way rand paul saying this
is unconstitutional
and then when you ask him why he says
well because we did it differently in
the past
and you can file criminal charges and
trump was already embarrassed
and it would divide the country that's
not an argument about constitutionality
in an in an ideal world we would have a
level of education and media literacy
such that people would be able to
hear that and say none of what rand said
has anything to do with the issue of
constitutionality
his arguments are invalid completely
unfortunately
as we talked about with the laura
ingraham case
clip earlier where she says oh we've now
it's the real insurrection is biden and
people watch and they say yeah yeah
the real insurrection is biden the low
level
of media literacy makes it so that this
stuff actually has an effect and starts
to sort of
infect and pervade society and it's
unfortunately something that is
not easily solvable it's going to be a
long time
uh until that is completely completely
resolved so
it's disappointing we'll continue
exposing it uh but beyond that we
unless we really deal with the
educational problem in this country
that's not going to get fixed and it's a
cultural problem as well
it's a combination of the two and these
cultural education it's a cultural
educational problem
and um it took decades as i've pointed
out for it to get this bad
it's not super realistic to think in six
months we're going to fix it
so it's uh it's an uphill battle to say
the least one of our sponsors
is hydrant which is a delicious fruit
drink powder that you mix
into water for rehydration and they're
giving you 25
off your first order it's made with four
key
electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great it's made with real
fruit juice it's been a great part of my
daily routine for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus
and hydrant is the perfect way to
rehydrate especially because it's cost
effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant immunity packed with
vitamins a
b c and d which is also very much worth
trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video